du football maintenant les français ont
gagné tous leurs matches cette année
c'est fait avec la dernière victoire
hier soir contre l'allemagne de l'est 2
à 0 les français sont donc premiers de
leur groupe éliminatoire pour la
prochaine coupe du monde
sylvie josse et olivier ray sans
quatrième et dernier match de fernand
sastre à la tête de la fédération
française de football avec le geste de
platini qui lui remet le fanion du match
et monsieur sastre n'a pas dû s'ennuyer
au spectacle offert par l'équipe de
france
29e minute occasion manquée verdien par
yannick stopyra bien lancé par giresse
le toulousain voit son ballon heurter le
poteau gauche du but de müller côté
poteau ce n'est d'ailleurs qu'un début
pour l'équipe de france
33e minute c'est le premier but français
sur une ouverture de platini bibard
prolonge pour stopyra qui mate
en vue plutôt heureux puisque vivar
bénéficie d'un contre favorable et ne
contrôle pas parfaitement son ballon
mais stopyra est là
à nouveau le poteau ou plutôt l'angle du
but qui ont un superbe tir de manuel
amoros des 30 mètres en deuxième
mi-temps les allemands de l'est se
montrent plus agressifs et se créent
plusieurs occasions comme ici par
l'intermédiaire de stein par les
français eux continuent d'attaquer pour
se mettre à l'abri d'un éventuel retour
au score des allemands et après ce beau
travail de platini s'est une nouvelle
fois le poteau qui sauve muller
enfin un peu comme contre l'espagne en
finale du championnat d'europe à la
dernière minute sur un pur mellon
s'échappe et il offre le deuxième but à
philippe anziani qui venait d'entrer en
jeu
un but qui intervient quelques secondes
seulement avant la fin de la rencontre
trois matches en poule de qualification
pour le mondial 86 3 victoires 6 points
pour l'équipe de france le contrat est
rempli
je souhaitais avoir six points au bout
de trois matches et ce qu'ont joué deux
fois chez nous et ont joué contre le
luxembourg à l'extérieur on a réussi
mais la plus belle chose et quand même
que en un an il y en a fait deux matches
on a gagné 12 et je vois que dans
l'histoire du football européen voire
mondial certainement français ya je
pense pas qu'ils aient une équipe qui
fume il